one of the process that we have with
cannabis today which is really
interesting
was that it's not the same plan it was
40 years ago yeah so you can't get I saw
this for an officer and guys are
listening out there with referred to the
law enforcement side of it too much THC
is a bad thing
because it makes you feel paranoid so
Yuki HC makes you feel paranoid see too
much THC and cannabis will make you
paranoid okay so what I see is all
everybody's worried about this THC we're
gonna breed these things to be like Oh
Morty that's not the idea because who
wants to sit around and think oh god am
I getting busted or anything oh yeah
somebody's looking at me oh man so
you're not gonna when I see officers
talk about oh it's just me they're grown
in this grill house over here and it's
it's 40 times stronger that's that's a
false statement they put this again in
the wrong light that's not how this
works
when you start looking at when I stalk
to some of the geneticists understanding
I'm a I'm thinking like these guys are
working on your own magnifying glass and
they're you know pulling out the
chromosomes and the seed and they're
genetically putting them together when
the fact is I'd like to ask the guys how
do you do that Manny goes here's what we
do because I take a hundred seeds I
planned them out of the hundred plants
one of them is different I won't
understand why that one's different what
are the characteristics so I pulled that
plant in and start looking at what what
goes on and all of a sudden I find out
that it has a different color or a
different CBD or it's maybe there's a
little stronger you know we want to use
this for a different process so because
that's how we do this there's no gene
splicing it's not genetically done
obviously if you grow it indoors you get
four great grows a year it's the perfect
weather every day you can control bugs
you can control but it's not full
spectrum the plants that grow outside
our full spectrum Sun so you're getting
every bit of that full radiation of the
Sun every single day so there's people
that will say oh well that's because
it's grown indoors it's not quite as
good as the outdoor stuff and what do
you define is good me this good mean
higher THC not necessarily higher THC
greater looking plant maybe a bigger
plant feels more product some of the
funny attributes about cannabis is as it
gets stale and cannabis does get stale
it gets very very high in CBD
as it gets higher in CBD and it gets
more stale it makes you want to go to
sleep
okay so there's different ways you can
bring this to the market with regards
and how you want to show the cannabis
itself it's all pretty much the same
you've got sent Eva and you've got
indigo yeah
people talk about hybrids or what
they're doing I'm not really sure in the
bigger picture how that all works but
when you kind of look at it all looks
the same
the way they trim the buds up is pretty
much the same the way they process is
pretty much the change everybody tries
to come up with a different a different
branding perspective as an example one
of the guys that we work with one the
new vets groups wanted to private label
some cannabis and so we were looking at
trying to figure out a great name for
this and so as we're sitting around kind
of brainstorming hey what would be a
good name for this one of the guys came
back in and said hey I just got to walk
on my dog and it took me from the time I
left the house to walk the dog I smoked
one joint so he came up with dog walkers
nice and so all of a sudden dude now
it's vet it's a veteran-owned process we
call them dog walkers they come in a
little you know a little okay so the
little tin with the little joints in it
thank God you saw them yes oh yeah
things are awesome that and they're
called dog walk I love those things and
what a simple name and it has taken off
like you can't believe and it's a it's a
you know standard sativa sativa is kind
of up you know you want to you know on
the high side of it it kind of helps you
go to sleep at night and so I see that
when these guys participate they take
the sativa obviously they're much more
happier much more content right helps me
focus it's funny when you talk to
different people about different ways
that it affects them it's amazing across
the board yeah obviously for the vet
side of it most of these guys do it to
treat themselves it might before they go
to sleep but I always hear about the
great sleep that they get so I always
concur agem get the indica yeah I'm
getting the indica you know go that
route right yeah so when it works out
nice that's amazing